tattoos are designed to last a lifetime
but what if you don't want to keep it
that long
luckily there's a way to remove it with
lasers here's how it works
ii the tattoo ache penetrates the skin
your immune system sounds a red alert
white blood cells rush to the injection
site to inspect the intruder tattoo week
is often made of heavy metals that your
blood cells can't recognize so they
immediately start attacking it and
escorting it towards the exit your
kidneys but there's a problem your blood
cells are miniscule in size compared to
ink droplets it's like a human trying to
move a gigantic Boulder your cells can
rage war for decades but the tattoo will
remain intact that's where the laser
comes in energy from the laser acts like
a giant sledgehammer it heats up the ink
in your skin breaking ink droplets apart
into smaller pieces
now the ink is easier for white blood
cells to carry away it can take over a
dozen laser sessions to help your body
fully remove a tattoo that's something
to think about before you go under the
needle
[Music]